and the culinary workers and dee and geo
and
listen um i was raised
to understand that
if you lived the value of love thy
neighbor
you understand the distinction between
charity
and duty charity
i'll give you a little if i've got a
little extra look at how wonderful i am
i'm so benevolent
duty it is the the business of each of
us we have a duty
to help each other out especially in
times of need
it is our responsibility when people are
suffering
when people are hungry you help people
out
and you do it understanding the dignity
of each person and your fellow human
being
and that's what this is about that's
what you all are doing here
that's what we were doing with the
american rescue plan
about understanding that right now in
our country people are suffering
people have been unemployed for over a
year through
no fault of their own our babies are
hungry
in nevada alone one in seven households
are describing hunger in their household
in nevada alone
one in five whole households is
describing
an inability or a difficulty to pay rent
in nevada alone one in four small
businesses is out of business
so president biden you'll remember a
while back he said help is on the way
and then he signed that american rescue
plan so i would say
help is here help is here
help is here and as the congressman said
there are a number of things that it
does
and so i'm here to also make sure we get
the word out
so folks know what they are entitled to
receive and also by extension they
remember
this is supposed to be the job of your
government
which is when you're suffering when you
need a helping hand
when you need a little assistance just
get over a moment of
crisis you didn't create that's when
leaders are supposed to kick in to say
i'm here i see you and i will help you
so it's the 1400 direct payment
it's the extensive on unemployment
benefits
that child tax credit d says people
don't understand what that means but let
me just
i'm gonna try to explain to you
basically means if you have children
and you don't neces don't normally pay
taxes at a high level so you get the tax
credit but you pay at a lower level so
you may not get the money back because
because you haven't paid the tax on it
you still get that assistance because
everybody should get
the equal amount it's about saying about
equity
and you know what equity is about you
know i come from parents who fought for
civil rights right
and the fight was for equality
the point about equity is to understand
also
not everybody starts out on the same
base
some people start out on first base some
people start out in third base
the point of equality the spirit behind
it is we should all kind of end up in
the same place have an equal opportunity
to compete an equal opportunity to
prosper
so equity says let's take into account
not everybody starts out on the same
base
that's what is part of the the spirit
behind the american rescue plan
it's saying that children should not
live in poverty
in america and so it will lift
half of america's children out of
poverty here in nevada
that'll be of estimated 40 000 children
lifted out of poverty so these are the
things we are doing but
the importance of also looking at things
like
cobra is understanding workers
i've been talking with workers in the
culinary
union who in cases worked 30 years where
they worked
20 years where they worked 15 years
where they worked and they're now out of
work
and so health benefits right culinary
workers in particular but national
leaders in fighting for workers rights
around health care
so we're going to extend cobra benefits
so you don't have to
come out of your pocket to pay what your
employer was paying for health care when
you're out of a job through no fault of
your own
these are some of the things that we are
doing with the american rescue plan but
i'm going to end with a story
that i heard from dr scott that
really i think makes such a point about
the human spirit in times of crisis
and it makes such an important point
about the
dignity that each one of us has
and that we should respect in each other
and so he told me about how here
you've been packing up the bags so that
people can drive up
and because kovid there's no direct
interaction and
folks pop open their trunk
and how the volunteers here when they go
to take the bags
to put in the trunk of the car they look
down
and there are handwritten notes
from the family who was the occupant of
the car
thanking you
for the extension of humanity
the extension of dignity
told me about sometimes the volunteers
will pop open
the trunk or the trunk will open and
they look down
and there's a five dollar bill as a tip
to the volunteers
from people who are barely making
it all work who have
nothing extra to give
and are tipping the volunteers out of
respect for the dignity of your work
i think in moments of crisis
it presents a real measure
of each of us and what we are prepared
to do
and i will say i was at unlv earlier
and i met with all the healthcare
workers there i'm here
with all these volunteers you are the
heroes of this moment
this crisis has been a measure
of character and of who the heroes
that history will tell kept it all going
and gave people the dignity they deserve
so on behalf of president biden and
myself
and our country i'm here to thank all of
you
for all you do and have been doing thank
you